[Musik]
der Anschlag auf die nordstreams hat den
Europäern wieder einmal die Fragilität
ihrer Energieversorgung vor Augen
geführt während die Untersuchungen noch
laufen ist es schwer zu sagen wer für
die Explosion verantwortlich ist wieso
oft bleibt uns da nur die Frage wie Bono
wer profitiert davon dass Nord Stream
außer Gefecht gesetzt worden ist und
wohl auch nie wieder betriebsfähig
werden wird falls eine Reparatur nicht
schnell erfolgt aufgrund der Korrosion
durch das Salzwasser oberflächlich
betrachtet fallen einem der natürlich
die USA als Hauptverdächtiger ein sie
waren immer gegen Nordring gewesen und
mit der Kappung der Pipeline aus
Russland bekommen ihre lng-produzenten
einen großen Vorteil wenn man das Ganze
jedoch etwas genauer unter die Lupe
nimmt fällt einem ein kleines wenn auch
entscheidendes Detail auf die Explosion
haben beide Stränge von Nord Stream ein
zerstört jedoch nur eine Röhre von
nordstring 2 durch nordstring 1 floss
jedoch sowieso schon seit einigen Wochen
kein Gas mehr da Gasprom den Betrieb
unter scheinheiligen Vorwänden
Behinderte bei nordstring 2 sieht es
jedoch ganz anders aus diese Pipeline
wollte Putin unbedingt in Betrieb nehmen
die deutsche Regierung unter
Federführung der Grünen verweigerte
jedoch nach dem russischen Angriff auf
die Ukraine die Genehmigung dafür durch
den Anschlag auf nordstream1 entsteht
für Gastraum also die Situation das ist
aus dem Lieferverträgen über nostream 1
aussteigen kann ohne den deutschen dafür
Schadensersatz und Vertragsstrafen
zahlen zu müssen falls es vor Gericht
dann mit dem Argument der höheren Macht
aufgrund der Explosionen durchkommt
andererseits hat Putin jetzt
einschlagenes Argument mehr wieso die
Deutschen die Betriebsgenehmigung von
Nord Stream 2 erteilen sollten um
zumindest die Hälfte davon nutzen zu
können falls es im Winter hart auf hart
kommt tja es bleibt spannend und wir
werden dieses hochposante Pokerspiele
nächster Zeit in vielen weiteren Videos
analysieren heute möchten wir uns eine
Frage widmen die angesichts der sich
überschlagenen Ereignisse besonders
bringt könnte amerikanisches Gas Europa
wirklich vor einer Energiekrise im
Winter retten wie ist der russisch
europäische Gaskrieg im globalen Maßstab
einzuordnen nun fakt ist mehr als ein
Jahrzehnt verfehlte Energie und
Außenpolitik hauptsächlich der Deutschen
haben Kombination mit unzureichenden
Investitionen in die Öl- und
gasförderindustrie und der russischen
Invasion in die Ukraine zu einer tiefen
Energiekrise geführt die jetzt viele
Volkswirtschaften auf der ganzen Welt
Herr trifft aber es gibt auch Profiteure
dieser Krise und bei dieser Gelegenheit
werden wir weder über erneuerbare
Energien noch über Kernenergie sprechen
nicht einmal über Wasserstoff nein heute
geht es um etwas das kurz und
mittelfristig vielleicht viel wichtiger
ist um die Energieversorgung von Putins
ehemaligen Kunden sicherzustellen ich
spreche natürlich von verflüssigten
Erdgas also Liquid fight natural gas
kurz LMG die LNG Produzenten zählen ja
schon seit Beginn des Krieges mit zu den
wichtigsten Protagonisten im
ökonomischen Nachrichten aus aller Welt
immerhin verfügen über die Schlüssel
Ressource welche die Weltwirtschaft in
den kommenden Jahren bestimmen wird dazu
nehmen wir besonders Europa ins Visier
und betrachtet die dortigen Probleme
sowohl von der Nachfrageseite als auch
von der Angebotsseite aus sprich welche
Probleme stehen in Europa eine
diversifizierten Gasversorgung im Weg
kann es auf diese Weise energetische
Resilienz sicherstellen und mehr
profitiert von der Situation auf der
Angebotsseite besonders also auch
gepasst denn am Ende dieses Videos
werdet ihr im nachrichten-dschungel zum
Thema Gasversorgung und LNG den vollen
Durchblick haben
[Musik]
[Applaus]
bevor wir mit unseren heutigen Thema
fortfahren muss ich euch kurz erklären
warum ist sie heute anders aussieht ja
ich nehme dieses Video im Urlaub auf
manchmal braucht man eben etwas Erholung
um danach wieder voll durchstarten zu
können und in den nächsten Tagen ist
wirklich etwas ganz Besonderes am Start
unser neuer Kanal visual economic.de den
könnt ihr schon heute abonnieren und
euch für den Countdown zu Premiere
seines ersten Videos anmelden es wird
darin um Benzinpreis Manipulation gehen
und ihr werdet sehen dass wir da einige
wirklich sehr interessante Zusammenhänge
als Tageslicht befördert haben also
lasst euch das Premieren Video auf
visual economic auf keinen Fall entgehen
den Link dazu habe ich euch in die
Beschreibung oder dieses Video gepackt
so und nun wieder zurück zum Thema LNG
[Musik]
LNG erhält man wenn man gefördertes
Erdgas auf etwa 160°c unter Null abkühlt
[Musik]
bei dieser Temperatur wird das Gas
flüssig und nimmt somit viel weniger
Volumen ein um genau zu sein eine
Volumeneinheit verflüssigten erdgasis
würde im gasförmigen Zustand das
600-fache an Raum einnehmen mit den
eignet sich LNG also viel besser um Gas
auch per Schiff und nicht bloß per
Pipeline zu transportieren damit läutete
die Entwicklung von wirtschaftlichen
Produktionsverfahren auf diesem Gebiet
eine massive Liberalisierung am Gasmarkt
ein jetzt konnten nicht mehr nur die
Länder ihr Gas verkaufen die in der Nähe
von großen verbrauchanlagen und
umgekehrt konnten nun auch die Länder
große Mengen an gaseinkaufen die nicht
das Glück haben in der Nähe großer
Gasfelder zu liegen 1964 wurde das erste
Schiff Indiz gestellt das ausschließlich
für den lng-export bestimmt war
[Musik]
von da an eroberte ein neuer
Energieträger die Welt der zudem noch
weniger umweltschädlich ist als andere
fossile Brennstoffe besonders in den
letzten 20 Jahren ist die Nachfrage fast
kontinuierlich exponentiell gewachsen
bis heute wurden weltweit mehr als
80.000 LNG Transporter durchgeführt mehr
als 600 Schiffe transportieren aktiv Gas
aus Förderländern wie Katar zu den
Heizkesseln der Verbraucher aus aller
Welt von Japan ist Spanien und von
Europa bis Südamerika es handelt sich um
eine richtige Revolution im Jahr 2021
waren übrigens die drei größten
Energieverbraucher China Japan und
Südkorea sie selbst und die Vorteile
liegen auf der Hand schaut euch zum
Beispiel Japan oder Südkorea an zwei
Nationen mit einem gigantischen
Energiehunger den sie lange zu einem
guten Teil mit relativ billigem LNG
stillen konnten damit ist LNG zu einer
wichtigen Stütze des Wachstums dieser
Volkswirtschaften geworden alles sollte
jedoch darauf hin dass die Bedeutung von
Flüssigkeit Erdgas in den nächsten
Jahren noch einmal sprunghaft ansteigen
wird
und für alle die in Europa leben ist der
Grund schon offensichtlich etwa 40% des
in Europa verbrauchten Gases kam direkt
über Pipelines aus Russland dieses Gas
kann man so großen Mengen und so
niedrigen Preisen dass die europäischen
Länder sehr abhängig wurden wie eine
Horde Junkies die alle an derselben
Nadel hängen aber wie so oft hat sich
gezeigt wer zu billig einkauft bezahlt
doppelt mindestens denn diese stark
Abhängigkeit bekommt man in Europa seit
Ausbruch des Krieges in der Ukraine
bitter zu spüren so heftig die
Abhängigkeit war so heftig sind nun die
Entzugserscheinungen einen Weg zurück
gibt es dabei nicht von ethischen
Erwägungen mal abgesehen ist das
Vertrauensverhältnis nachhaltig zerstört
zumal durch die Explosionen der Ostsee
die Verlässlichkeit dieser Transportwege
noch einmal deutlich vor Augen geführt
wurde resiliente Energiepolitik sieht
also wirklich ganz anders aus was auch
immer also passiert kaum ein
europäisches Land wird auf lange Sicht
bereits ein sich wieder abhängig von
Russland zu machen das Problem ist aber
das ist bisher ein Alternativen fehlt
über Jahrzehnte hinweg wurden
Investition eigenen alternative
Infrastruktur zu sehr vernachlässigt als
dass man nun schnell ohne weiteres weg
vom russischen Gas käme viele Orts war
die billige Energie aus Russland einfach
viel zu verlockend als dass es jemanden
eingefallen wäre zum Beispiel in teurer
lg-terminals und regazifizierungsanlagen
zu investieren aber natürlich gilt das
nicht in allen Fällen es gab schon
einige welche die Gefahr von Anfang an
ganz klar erkannt hatten
Litauen gibt als erstes EU-Mitglied
russisches Gas auf
der litauische LNG Terminalbetreiber
gleitpedos navta gibt grünes Licht für
die Entscheidung über den Erwerb von
fsru independence kN hat ein
Entscheidung über den Erwerb der fsru
Independence von Höch LNG nach Ablauf
des backvertrags im Jahr 2024 getroffen
der kleine baltische Staat mit weniger
als 3 Millionen Einwohner hat es
geschafft in Kurzzeit komplett vom
russischen Gas loszukommen
dies geschah durch die Inbetriebnahme
der schwimmenden wieder
verdampfungsanlage independence im Jahr
2014 und zwar genau deshalb um notfalls
auf Russland verzichten zu können den
Balken saß die russische Bedrohung eben
noch mehr in den Knochen neben den
strategischen Vorteilen für das eigene
Land konnte Litauen durch die neue
Infrastruktur übrigens zu dem Gas auch
nach Lettland Estland und Finnland
exportieren ihr seht also die
frühzeitige strategische Entscheidung
für energetische Diversifizierung hat
sich dort gelohnt aber wie ist es
möglich dass andere Länder Europas nicht
auch schon 2014 nach der Besetzung der
Creme verstärkt auf Alternativen zu
russische Energie gesetzt haben allen
voran Deutschland nun darüber werden wir
ein separates Video drehen aber schaut
euch jetzt zunächst mal diese
Schlagzeile an
die russische Spione soll laut Bericht
die deutsche Regierung infiltriert haben
der inhaltsgeheimdienst soll gegen zwei
Beamte ermitteln die an der
Energieversorgung arbeiten
[Musik]
der russische Krieg in der Ukraine die
Sanktion die energieerpressung durch den
Kreml all das zwingt Europa dazu Knall
auffallen nach Alternativen zu Russland
zu suchen und da die Nachbarn die in der
Lage sind Gas durch Pipeline zu liefern
wie Algerien Aserbaidschan oder sogar
Israel nicht ausreichend um Russland
vollständig zu ersetzen sind jetzt drei
kleine Buchstaben in allen Ecken des
alten Kontinents zu hören LN und damit
Europa LNG in großen Mengen nutzen kann
sind vier Dingen nötig erstens eine
ausreichende Gasproduktion zweitens eine
ausreichende verflüchtigungskapazität in
Ursprungsland drittens viele verfügbare
LNG Tanker und viertens genügend wieder
verdampfungsanlagen am Zielort das ist
im Grunde die Lieferkette für flüssig
Erdgas und da das Angebot in
Mitteleuropa knapp ist werden wir den
kommenden Monaten und Jahren
medizinischer Sicherheit große
Investitionen in diesen Bereichen sehen
würden
Europas Ansturm auf neue lng-import
Infrastrukturen nimmt an Fahrt auf
Ukraine kriegt bringt Pläne für deutsche
lng-terminals wieder auf den Tisch diese
Investitionen noch am Anfang stehen
brechen die lng-importer schon jetzt
alle Rekorde
[Musik]
übrigens könnt ihr erraten welches
europäische Land die Best ausgebaute
lng-infrastruktur hat ne 321 genau
Spanien nun auch andere Länder haben
bereits in diesen Bereich investiert nur
in die meisten nicht genug als dass sich
eine resiliente System ergeben hätte
schaut euch mal diese Karte an auch ihr
sehen wir das europäische Netz und wie
ihr sehen könnt ist Spanien das Land mit
den meisten in Betrieb befindlichen
regazifizierungsanlagen
Spanien allein verfügt über nicht
weniger als 27% aller
wiederverdampfungskapazitäten in Europa
und mehr als ein Drittel derzeitigen
Speicherkapazität im Jahr 2021 nutze
Spanien jedoch nur etwa 30% dieser
Kapazitäten mit anderen Worten der
Überschuss für die Versorgung Europas
ihre ziemlich groß allerdings gibt es
ein Problem Spanien ist in Sachen
Energie praktisch eine Insel es gibt nur
eine Gaspipeline die nach Frankreich
führt und deren Kapazität ist ziemlich
begrenzt nun sollte man meinen dass sich
das wenigstens mittelfristig ändern
ließe aber da spielen die Franzosen
nicht mit
[Applaus]
Deutschlands Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz
schlägt eine Gaspipeline vor die Spanien
und Portugal mit dem Rest Europas
verbindet
Spanien Gaspipeline nach Frankreich in
acht bis neun Monaten möglich
[Musik]
Frankreich zerschlägt Deutschlands
größte Hoffnung auf eine Wiederbelebung
seiner Wirtschaft Spanisch Beamte
vermuten das Paris die Konkurrenz für
seine Wasserstoff energieexporte
fürchtet Paris betont das Berlins Plan
unpraktikabel ist das französische
Ministerium beklagt dass es viele Jahre
dauern würde allein die Planung und
andere Unterlagen fertig zu stellen
alles beim schlechten alten im guten
alten Europa also aber über die Rolle
Spaniens als möglicher Erretter in der
Energiekrise werden wir bald ein
separates Video bringen gut aber auf der
Nachfrageseite sieht es schon einmal
schwierig aus wie sieht's aber auf der
Angebotsseite aus nun auch hier gibt es
Probleme die Industrie ist fast
vollständig ausgelastet und es wird ein
paar Jahre dauern bis deutlich mehr Gas
geliefert werden kann doch unter
Berücksichtigung dieser Schwierigkeiten
gibt es ein Land das den Europäer
liebend gern zur Seite springen würde
richtig der Titel dieses Videos gibt
euch schon einen kleinen Hinweis es geht
um die
us-ofa ist bei Uncle Sam also plötzlich
Altruismus ausgebrochen nun schauen wir
mal nach
USA Europas letzte Hoffnung
zunächst einmal die USA sind natürlich
nicht die einzigen lng-anbieter in einem
früheren Video haben wir euch erzählt
wie kathara zu einem der größten Könige
flüssiggasexporte geworden ist zusammen
mit Australien in den USA ist es eine
der drei größten lng-mächte der Welt
allerdings hat der Start am Persischen
Golf ein Problem der größte Teil seines
aktuell förderbaren Gases ist bereits im
Rahmen von langfristigen Verträgen
verkauft dort kann man also nicht so
einfach auf eine plötzliche
nachfrageexplosion reagieren zumindest
nicht bis Ende 2025 bis dahin soll die
katarischen Fördermenge enorm
ausgeweitet werden in Australien ist die
Lage ähnlich außerdem sind beide
Produzenten aufgrund ihrer Lage mehr für
den asiatischen als für den europäischen
Markt prädestiniert denn desto kürzerer
Weg desto weniger Schiffe braucht man um
die gleiche Menge Gas pro Zeiteinheit zu
transportieren von den drei größten
energy Exporteuren bietet sich für
Europa also vor allem die USA hier gibt
es zudem noch einen weiteren Vorteil
die Menge an Gasleitung die USA auch
kurzfristig auf den Markt werfen können
ist viel größer als die von Katar oder
Australien das liegt unter anderem daran
dass die USA über große Gasmengen
verfügen wie sie bis vor ein paar Jahren
gar nicht exportiert haben seither
bereitet man sich dort jedoch darauf vor
dies zu tun das verspricht einem
multimilladen
seht euch noch einmal die Grafik an die
wir gerade gezeigt haben habt ihr
gesehen wie die Exporte aus dem
Vereinigten Staaten gewachsen sind und
anders als einige behaupten liegt hier
denn keine Berührung sondern eine große
Hoffnung für die Wirtschaft Europas
die USA sind zum Schlüsselland für die
europäische Energieversorgung in den
kommenden Jahren geworden denn die
Europäische Union hat sich zum Ziel
gesetzt dass die Mitgliedsländer bis
spätestens 2027 vollständig auf
russisches Gas verzichten können und um
dieses Ziel zu erreichen wird kein Weg
an den USA vorbei
die USA sind zum weltgrößten
lng-exporter geworden da sie den von der
Gnade Russlands abhängigen europäischen
Verbrauchern Versorgung anbieten die
US-Industrie ist auf diesem Gebiet mit
voller Kraft auf die Vormarsch und
Europa ist ihr bevorzugter Kunde
geworden zum Vergleich während die USA
im Jahr 2021 durchschnittlich 29% ihres
gesamten energy nach Europa exportierten
waren es in den ersten drei Monaten 2022
bereits mehr als 60% und tatsächlich
können Sie noch deutlich mehr liefern
schaut euch diese Grafik an mit der
Erdgasproduktion in den USA
wie ihr seht ist die Produktion in den
letzten 15 Jahren dank einer neuen
Technologiesprung habt angestiegen und
zwar Fracking tatsächlich macht es
Schiefer Erdgas wie das durch das
Fracking Gas genannt wird im Jahr 2021
und 79% des gesamten in den USA
geförderten Gases aus und das enorme
Wachstum der Gasproduktion hat dazu
geführt dass sie den heimischen
Verbrauch bei weitem übersteigt das
alles zusammen ermöglicht den
Vereinigten Staaten nun Gas in großen
Mengen zu exportieren wie wir bereits in
der Vergangenheit hier official Politik
berichtet haben war die Fracking
Technologie ein echter Wendepunkt
[Musik]
dadurch haben sich die verfügbaren Öl-
und Gasreserven vervielfacht eine
Tatsache welche man in den USA extrem
ausnutzt da Europa sicher aus dieser
Technologie weit geht zurückgezogen hat
es wird erwartet dass die USA bis zum
Ende dieses Jahrzehnts mindestens ein
Drittel des Gases substituieren können
dass der alte Kontinent früher aus
Russland bezog und das spielt auch
reichlich Geld in die amerikanischen
Kassen
von 50 billion
States Android bei twenty thirty aber
die USA sind nicht die einzige Option
für Europa und können es im übrigen auch
nicht sein selbst wenn man die erhöhte
Förderung in kataren vielen anderen
Ländern berücksichtigt bleibt es
fraglich ob das russische Gas
langfristig ganz substituiert werden
kann eine davon scheint nahezulegen wird
bisher aber noch ausgeschlossen seht
euch mal die folgende Karte an auf ihr
seht ihr die Ergebnisse einer Studie der
US energy Information agency aus dem
Jahr 2011 in ein Großteil der
geschätzten schiefergas-reserven der
Welt zusammengetragen wurde außerdem hat
die europäische Mission in einem Bericht
aus dem Jahr 2017 selbst 49 der 81
geschätzten Schiefergas Vorkommen auf
dem alten Kontinent bewertet das
Ergebnis war das bereits diese 49
vorkommen mindestens 90 Billionen
Kubikmeter schiefe Erdgas enthalten die
direkt den europäischen Markt zugeführt
werden könnten das würde ausreichend
fast 2 Jahrhunderte des aktuellen
europäischen Verbrauchs zu decken
angesichts dieser Daten und den hohen
Preisen ist es durchaus möglich dass
Europa einen guten Teil seines
Verbrauchs durch eigene Gasvorkommen
decken könnte mit anderen Worten der
Unterschied zwischen den USA und Europa
besteht im wesentlichen darin dass man
in Amerika das Risiko eingeht und
potenzielle ökologische Folgen in Kauf
nimmt und mit dieser Branche Geschäfte
zu machen das verschafft den USA nicht
nur eine direkten finanziellen Vorteil
viel mehr sorgt es auch dafür dass
aufgrund der geringen Energiekosten
zahlreiche europäische Unternehmen über
den Atlantik wandern werden schon jetzt
werden einige US-Bundesstaaten fast
aggressiv um solche Übersiedler folgt
diesem Hintergrund scheint es also
fraglich ob die EU ihre halt Fracking
perspektivisch noch halten kann aber
lassen wir uns nicht ablenken denn trotz
allem taucht diese Möglichkeit bisher
nicht in den Plenen Puzzles auf und
nicht zuletzt deswegen war sich Europa
eben in den Fuß schießen will werden die
USA zu einem immer wichtigeren Akteur
auf dem internationalen Gasmarkt es ist
ein neues Geschäft das jedes Jahr zig
Milliarden Dollar einbringen wird für
die USA ist der internationale
Schlamassel zumindest unter dieser
Perspektive also gar nicht mal so
schlecht für Europa wirkt er hingegen
noch ein weiteres Problem Europa ist
nicht der einzige Kunde der um Gas auf
dem Weltmarkt konkurriert und die
Konkurrenz ist wahrlich hart so dass die
Anbieter aktuell klar im Vorteil sind
aber inwiefern genau habt ihr schon mal
um dieses weitere Problem Europas zu
verstehen gefragt warum der Gaspreis
plötzlich so dermaßen stark gestiegen
ist nun hör zu
der Gaskrieg
[Musik]
der Krieg in der Ukraine und die
europäischen Sanktionen haben nicht nur
die Gaspreise in die Höhe schnellen
lassen sondern auch die Grundlagen des
Marktes erschüttert Länder wie Südkorea
und Japan haben seit Jahren vor allem
oft flüssig Erdgas gesetzt weil es
bisher eine relativ stabile und wenig
volatile Versorgungsquelle war ein
zuverlässiger und berechenbarer Markt
mit wenigen Preissprüngen der eine
sichere und konstante Versorgung
sicherte aber all das war einmal zum
Zeitpunkt des Drehs dieses Videos geht
es auf dem lng-markt zu wie auf einem
Basar da wird noch um den letzten
irgendwie freien Punker geschachert und
der Meistbietende bekommt am Ende die
ganze Ladung
obwohl die meisten Männer sich vor allem
durchlieferungen aus langfristigen
Verträgen mit Gas versorgen ein Teil der
Nachfrage doch meist durch den Spotmarkt
gedeckt das heißt man kauft je nach
Bedarf tangerladungen auf dem freien
Markt aber dieser Markt ist eben gerade
außer Rand und Bahn es gibt sogar
ärmere Länder außerhalb Europas die
Gefahr laufen dass ihnen das Gas ausgeht
einfach deswegen weil sie nicht mehr
etwaige Versorgungslücken am Spotmarkt
ausgleichen können
südasiatische Käufer werden durch hohe
lng-spot Preise erneut ins Abseits
gedrängt um euch eine Vorstellung dafür
zu geben wie das vonstatten geht es gibt
viele Fälle in denen Schiffe die bereits
mit LG beladen sind und nach Asien
fahren plötzlich ihren Kurs nach Europa
ändern weil man dort mehr dafür bezahlen
will das passiert vor allem bei Ladungen
aus den USA und Australien für die das
sogenannte free onboard-system gilt
darin ist der Zwischenhändler selbst
Eigentümer des auf seinen Schiffen
transportierten Gases daher wird auf der
Reise zum vorläufigen Stil Hafen noch
munter weiter verhandelt ob sich nicht
doch noch ein Hörer wieder findet und
gegebenenfalls ändert man dann eben
schnell den Kurs auf diese Weise ist ein
gigantischer vitak zwischen Europa und
Asien ausgebrochen was die Preise noch
mehr in die Höhe getrieben hat
[Musik]
während us-lg im Jahr 2021 im
Durchschnitt zwischen 4 und 8 Dollar pro
Millionen britischer wärmeeinheiten
verkauft wurde ist der Futures Preis
inzwischen auf 60 oder sogar 70 $
gestiegen und nicht nur das insgesamt
kostet das nach Europa transportierte
LNG in den ersten drei Monaten des
Jahres 2022 durchschnittlich mehr als 30
Dollar und war damit etwa 7 mal so teuer
wie im Vorjahr natürlich haben die
europäischen Länder vor allem die mit
kälteren Wintern oder gasintensiven
Industrien versucht um jeden Preis ihre
Reserven für den Winter aufzufüllen das
trägt den Preis dann endgültig durch die
Decke zumal darf man nicht vergessen
dass durch die Zentralbankpolitik
parallel noch der Euro gegenüber dem
Dollar abwertete so dass die Preise für
die Europäer noch einmal gesteigert
wurden über die Themen
Zentralbankpolitik Euro Absturz ohne
Inflation werden wir übrigens bald
Videos auf visual economic bringen in
den kommenden Videos hier auf
visualpolitik zum Thema Gas und Energie
werden wir uns in Frage widmen wie genau
es aus historischer Sicht zum Beispiel
überhaupt zu dieser katastrophalen
Situation kommen konnte und glaub mir
wir werden nicht nur sehr tief dabei
bohren dran wahrlich zu Rundumschlag
ausholen schließlich dürft ihr euch aber
auch auf mehrere weitere Videos freuen
in denen wir auch Wege aus der Krise
aufzeigen und zwar sowohl kurz und
mittelfristige als auch langfristige und
strategische vergesst also bitte nicht
visualpolitik und auch visual economic
zu abonnieren und auch das Glöckchen zu
aktivieren ich verspreche euch es wird
sich lohnen aber gut jetzt wo wir wissen
welche Rolle die USA spielen und was ist
mit den Gaspreisen auf sich hat seid ihr
mit eurer Meinung an der Reihe glaubt
ihr dass die Vereinigten Staaten eine
gute und sichere Alternative zum
russischen Gas sein könnten werden die
europäischen Länder es schaffen den
kalten Winter und die gasknappheit zu
überstehen bis die lng-infrastruktur
fertiggestellt ist welche anderen
Alternativen gibt es ich hoffe dass euch
dieses Video etwas gebracht hat was ja
gibt uns bitte ein Like und teils auch
fleißig mit euren Freunden natürlich
freuen wir uns auch jederzeit über eine
Spende von euch mit uns selbst dieses
Projekt weiterzuführen in PayPal Link
dazu findet ihr in der Beschreibung
unter dem Video macht's gut und bis bald
[Musik]